what we're going to do is we're going to
eliminate what we're trying to do is
we're trying to add the two equations
together to eliminate either the X
variable or the Y variables okay so we
can get it down to a one equation with
one variable so you can see if we try to
add these together nothing cancels out
the X's don't cancel the Y's don't
cancel so what we're going to do is
let's multiply this top equation times
four because that'll give us a negative
4y plus this 4y they're going to cancel
it one another out so we're gonna
multiply everything in the equation by
four so that gives you 20x minus 4y
equals 28 and in this equation we're
just going to bring over X plus 4y
equals 14 if we add them together you
can see the Y's are cancelling so that
gives you 21 x equals 42 which means
that x equals 2 if you put 2 back in you
can put it in for this equation or this
equation and you can solve for y so I'll
just put it into this top equation so
it's 5 times 2 minus y equals 7 so
that's 10 minus y equals 7 subtract 10
so you can see y equals 3 so our final
result is 2 comma 3 and you can double
check your work you just have to put 2 &
3 back into both equations make sure
that they are both true and satisfied so
that's our first example okay let's look
at another example here here we've got X
plus 2y equals 6 negative 3x minus 6 y
equals 4 here what we'll do is we're
going to multiply the top equation times
positive 3 okay so that we can eliminate
the X's so if we do that we get 3x plus
6y equals 18 and then this one we're
just going to carry over negative 3x
minus 6y equals 4 and when we add the
X's cancel the Y's cancel we end up
getting 0 equals 22 now what does that
mean 0 equals 22 that's a that's a
nonsense right that's a nonsensical
answer doesn't make any sense
and what that actually tells us is that
these two lines are parallel so if you
were to graph them it would be like this
they don't cross so this one there's no
solution so empty set no solution or you
can just write no solution okay this
next one over here let's eliminate the
Y's we're going to multiply the top
equation times two so if we do that
we're gonna get 4x minus 2y equals 10 so
if we combine the top equation with the
bottom equation you can see the X's
cancel the Y's cancel and even these
numbers on the right side of the
equation cancel so we're getting 0
equals 0 what that tells us is that
these lines are the exact same line so
if you were to graph them one line would
be like this the other line would be
right on top of that line and they're
crossing at an infinite number of points
so this one is you know infinite number
of solutions or you could say consistent
dependent so consistent dependent this
one over here was inconsistent ok and
then these other ones that were working
on this is consistent independent okay
so this one here is a little different
example here we're gonna have to
multiply that both equations so that we
can eliminate one of the variables so
let's just say we want to eliminate the
the axes what does - and what does 5
what do they both go into evenly 10
that's the lowest common multiple but
let's make one of them negative 10 and 1
positive 10 so we're going to multiply
this top equation times 5 the bottom
equation times negative 2 okay so if we
do that we get 10x plus 15y equals
negative 5 and the bottom equation we
get negative 10x minus 8y equals
negative 2 if we add those together the
x's cancel we get 7y equals just check
in my math real quick make sure I didn't
make any mistakes so that's negative 7
and y equals 1 negative 1 okay so now we
know what y equals if we put it back
into this equation or this equation
we'll get the same answer
let's just put it to the top equation so
that
going to give us 2 X 3 times negative 1
is negative 3 add the 3 to the other
side we get 2 and divide by 2 x equals 1
so our solution is 1 comma negative 1
and that's where these two lines are
going to intersect